Corporate social responsibility or CSR
for short is the social responsibility
of companies as part of a sustainable
economy
an economy includes individuals
commercial entities and government
involved in the production distribution
exchange and consumption of products and
services in a society
together these activities help a nation
determine the availability and
distribution of scarce resources to meet
the needs of its people
stem also known as the economic system
allocates Land Resources labor and
capital to produce for consumption
in addition decision-making authorities
determine the value of goods and
services within a community the term
usually refers to a country and
describes its resources consumption
inflation economic growth and decline
however it can also describe the
economic structure of a city state local
market or if you look very closely also
a single company
some of these companies have gone
through a long phase of research and
testing of their products investors
needed a lot of staying power and their
business models were exposed to the
violent shocks of the market
in this documentary we will take a
closer look at some of these companies
and their path to success
many of them have had a tough road to
break even
one of the world's oldest airlines
flying the world's longest routes a
brand known across the globe but less
than a decade ago it was hemorrhaging
cash spiraling toward collapse
it's been transformed
[Music]
in 2018 Qantas reported a profit of 1.2
billion US Dollars its largest ever
shareholders were rewarded with shared
BuyBacks and dividends of more than 360
million dollars while employees were
showered with 50 million dollars of
bonuses
that was a far cry from the 2.7 billion
loss announced in 2014. there's no doubt
that today's numbers are confronted
but they represent the year that is
passed and we have now come through the
worst how do you nice to meet you thank
you nice to meet you David glad to be
here and welcome to Qantas head office
thank you very much so tell me about
that turn around what were the main
elements of the turnaround how did that
plan evolve so we had probably the
perfect storm hitting us down
um around 2013. so the conditions I
suppose are important because we had
high oil prices they reached uh well
over four billion dollars the highest
over a hundred dollars Barrel the
highest that we've seen we had
simultaneously a domestic competitor
virgin running errors and trying to take
massive market share and being funded by
a number of foreign Airlines extensively
funded and we also had because of the
very high Aussie dollar a lot of
international carriers flying into
Australia so it was The Perfect Storm on
all of our businesses simultaneously
voice announced a two billion dollar
cost cutting program everything from
faster aircraft turnarounds to saving
fuel from optimizing routes the
workforce shrank by 5 000 or 15 percent
the fleet was simplified Boeing 747s law
retired ahead of schedule replaced by A3
3200s
an order for eight a380s was deferred
and schedules were changed to maximize
the use of quantities remaining 12a 380s
Qantas dropped unprofitable routes like
Perth to Singapore
on other routes planes would change to
match capacity to demand Joyce himself
took a 36 pay cut
it was one of the most remarkable
aviation turnarounds in history
in 2020 Qantas will Mark its 100th year
a sense of that history I went to the
Qantas Heritage collection at Sydney's
domestic airport it's just near gate 13
in terminal 3. you can go there while
waiting for a flight so these were the
two Visionaries 1919. who were they
these are the founders of Qantas this is
Hudson fish and this is Paul McGinnis
the airline was born in 1920 founded by
two Veterans of Gallipoli the disastrous
World War one campaign often regarded as
The Crucible of the Australian Nation
Hudson fish and Paul McGinnis
established the Queensland and Northern
Territory aerial services to provide Air
transport over the huge distances of
Australia's North
but even then they had International
ambitions
just before World War II Qantas moved
from its headquarters in Queensland to
Sydney and when they actually moved down
from Brisbane to Sydney in 1938 they
packed up the entire contents of Qantas
head office in two flying boats and flew
them down in one weekend and where was
the runway the runway was actually at
Rose Bay which is on Sydney Harbor so
Sydney's First International Airport is
actually not here at mascot it's
actually on Sydney Harbor
this is Rose Bay where Qantas had its
first International airstrip it's still
used as a terminal and the boat planes
would take off from here on the long
journey to Singapore
the great hulking flying boots would
slowly steadily gutter speed faster and
faster until their 32 meter Wings lifted
them out of the water like huge graceful
water Birds soaring Into the Blue Yonder
during the decades after the war Qantas
established itself as Australia's
Premier carrier
embedding itself into the national
psyche by the early 2000s qantas's
domestic rival and set had collapsed and
a new entrant came into the market in
the form of Virgin blue Qantas decided
to establish its own cut price airline
Jetstar and a young Irishman named Alan
Joyce was chosen as CEO
[Music]
star
create what was probably the first
successful cut price airline subsidiary
of a full-service parent
he chose a headquarters near Melbourne
far from the Qantas headquarters in
Sydney and proved himself an able
negotiator one of the reasons that the
low-cost subsidiaries never worked
anywhere else in the world apart from
the fact that all the clever
consultancies said they wouldn't was
that there was always massive conflict
in terms of cannibalization
self-cannibalization of the product of
the mainstream carrier and that was
where it required more than just the
ability to set up a low-cost carrier but
also to negotiate all the different
issues of network of pricing and you
know to fight your way through probably
your biggest enemy which was your parent
in many ways success at Jetstar opened
the door to another chief executive role
the Flying Kangaroo itself
but Joyce was soon under attack from all
sides
[Music]
the dawn of the 21st century the Flying
Kangaroo was an essential link for
Australia and the rest of the world
but as a century progressed Qantas was
buffeted by International competition
and an unrest at home
we have decided to ground the Qantas
International and domestic fleets
immediately
I repeat we are grounding the Qantas
Fleet now there will be no further
Qantas domestic or International
departures anywhere in the world
Alan Joyce was appointed chief executive
of Qantas in 2008 just as the Australian
dollar started to climb attracting
International competition the oil price
started to increase
and some of qantas's dozen or so unions
began industrial action it was a
difficult time obviously after the when
we're coming out of the the global
recession
and and all Airlines were doing pretty
badly the airline business of course is
is riddled with unions I think Qantas at
the time had about 15 or 18 of them and
each of them has quite a considerable
amount of power because if you can
easily ground an airline by by
withholding your services which is a
which is a massive impact Joyce took his
own drastic action he closed down the
airline
the reaction was harsh the consequences
reverberated Nationwide the government
overall was concerned about the extreme
action taken by Qantas that had stranded
tens of thousands of passengers far away
from home having the balls to do it was
a
really a massive thing at the time it
sort of Fades into history now but
I think had had he not done that had I
not done that at the time Qantas would
be very much a
pale picture of what it is today go
right back to probably the most
controversial thing of your career which
was the lockout yeah why was it
necessary
well you probably were aware that we had
gone through a dispute for nearly a year
where three Workforce groups uh we were
acting in unison with each other we
started to lose a lot of money because
we were on reliable because there was a
lot of action happening and we started
losing 20 million a week we could have
given into the demands and this was in
2011 and we believe that those demands
would have restricted Qantas to failure
in the future I wouldn't have allowed
Qantas subsequently to do the turnaround
in 2013 and after the lockout the
workplace relations tribunal canceled
industrial action on both sides now the
Unions would have to resolve their
grievances by arbitration
it meant that Qantas could get back to
work
[Music]
in 2012 Qantas signed a partnership with
Emirates allowing it to deliver
passengers to Dubai from where they
could plug into dozens of routes into
Europe it gave Qantas access to all of
the routes Beyond Dubai that that
Emirates operated which was a massive
contrast to what Qantas had they had
basically London I think in Frankfurt at
that stage
just as the Emirates deal was settling
in Virgin Australia launched its brutal
price War
facing these pressures Joyce announced
his transformation program to A Chorus
of public criticism you had people
calling for your resignation there were
television polls no one it seemed was
supporting you except for the board how
did you keep the board on side as I
remember at that poll I was on a TV
program sunrise and they said I think I
probably forgot the stats now but they
said it just in a poll before I came on
I was announcing the turnaround plan
what we were doing to improve it and he
said 98 during the high 90s of people
want you to to resign and my answer
there was well it's not a popularity
contest and if you think doing the CEO
jobs popularity counselor she should be
doing it
um I'm here to work for the board and
for the shareholders and they're fully
supported me but how did you get the
support of the staff so we we figured
that some of the principles around the
transformation were it just could
wouldn't be a focus on financial
outcomes it actually had to have two
other things going at the same time it
had to deliver great customer outcomes
and we couldn't take anything from the
customer and I had to engage our people
and probably another stakeholder because
of the iconic brand that we are was the
general public so we spent a lot of time
on managing communicating and talking to
all the stakeholders to bring them
together that that said though
personally how did you take it I mean
did you sleep yeah actually quite good
one of the things I you know I worked in
Aer Lingus and was my first Aviation job
and one of the things that they trained
our management there and was mindfulness
which is a big thing these days as well
and allowing people to focus and when
you go home you know my partner Shane he
wanted to talk about what was in the
Press what was occurring as you can
imagine he was reading it and I didn't
because then I'm at home I've got to
switch off I'm going to block that out
and that helped me get through that
period but where does that come from I
mean one you must have a you know
extreme sense of self-belief where does
that sense of self-belief come from so I
think my parents have been always been
my role model so my mother she's only
four foot nine she's an Irish mother as
you can imagine and she's like one of my
brothers calls her the best
pound-for-pound fighter in probably
Dublin uh because she really
um has always stood up for the family
to bullies and she was a determined
individual still is and so you I always
got that sense of purpose from them and
my parents neither my parents finished
secondary education I was actually the
first in the family in our history of
our family to finish secondary let alone
tertiary education a lot of people
watching us talk right now are wondering
what lessons they can take away from
what happened uh during the Qantas
turnaround I would say that you you
develop a plan you get as much diversity
and collaboration together so around our
senior leadership table I've got four
females the other three gay men so we
got a very diverse group but I think
it's diversity of thinking in all many
different forms and I think well we're
very passionate about all forms of
diversity you know we're one of the
leaders on on the marriage equality the
debate here in Australia and giving the
amount of lgbti customers we have
um employees that we have and
shareholders that we have we thought was
a very important campaign for us to take
here to announce
Joyce's outspoken support for same-sex
marriage earned him an embarrassing
encounter in Perth
an anti-gay marriage activist pushed a
pie into his face so at the time it was
a bit of a surprise because I didn't
know what it was for and and I think
Jeffrey Thomas who was the journalist
interviewed me on the stage I think he
figured it out before I did and asked me
that question you'd think it was because
of your support for marriage equality
and it was a very angry forceful pie to
the phase it was very much a message of
that I want you to stop talking about a
you're a powerful gay man and I'm
threatened by your commentary and your
insistence on it
thank you
with Qantas back on a firmer Financial
footing Joyce is looking to the Future
and that's Ultra Long Haul by 2022 the
airline plans groundbreaking flights
from Sydney and Melbourne to London and
New York the routes are only possible
because of a wave of innovation in
aircraft design this technology changes
the game the pert London servers that
we've now operated for a year has been
the best new service in our 99-year
history the best customer ratings the
best financial performance we haven't
made money on the London market for 10
years since the global financial crisis
it made money from day one we're getting
94 C factors we're getting a premium
people willing to play more to fly
direct and we know if it works on Perth
it will work on Melbourne and Sydney to
London and Melbourne and Sydney to New
York to Chicago to Rio to Cape Town
[Music]
Captain slate how do you do David Queen
from Bloomberg
take a seat
[Music]
to make the turnaround work Joyce had to
have the buy-in from all parts of the
organization
Pilots now have to think about more than
just flying planes
flight management was like a really key
part of the turnaround tell us exactly
how that affected the the the the flight
management and and actually the partners
um with regards to aircraft utilization
um so we have some of the highest
utilization of any airlines in the world
at the moment the A330 that we're
sitting on at the moment they utilize up
to 18 hours a day so our networks team
have finally tuned our program so that
the aircraft are flying and it's a fine
balance between having them on the
ground for the required maintenance and
utilizing them and increasing our
Revenue we also did a big piece of work
on our 35-minute turnaround so to reduce
the turnaround of our domestic aircraft
we introduced dual door boarding and
disembarkation and we had a whole team
of Frontline people involved in the
workshopping around how we could do it
so obviously the juggling of cleaning
stuff catering engineering Etc so we've
got a very precise precision timing
schedule to ensure that happens within
35 minutes I find it really interesting
that you as a pilot are talking about
revenue and revenue targets and such
something new since you've been what 30
years I believe as a pilot with Qantas
if they would only
need craft but now we know we're in
really challenging environments um so
fuel efficiency so we've introduced a
whole lot of fuel efficiency measures
with regards to running our auxiliary
power units on the ground we've
implemented single engine tax in to save
you know a few kilos here and there but
across the year across the fleet it all
adds up so fuel saving is is very much
so this is our Central operations area
Qantas is ultra Long Haul program means
that optimizing routes is essential
Captain Alan Dickinson is the guy in
charge of developing the new flight
planning system we had an flight from
Sydney to Santiago which was probably a
really good example in that we could see
just by dipping down a little further
south than than normal it was able to
pick up a jet stream and then by just
dipping down a little bit further south
and then coming north a little bit
sooner than the old system would was
planning we were able to save a ton fuel
on that flight but when you look at this
system compared with the old Capricorn
system what sort of percentage savings
are we looking at so we will Target
we're hoping to achieve around the one
percent saving fuel saving
we are still this is a very new system
we're still in the process of
introducing the new system but we have
high levels of confidence that over the
you know the short term we will be able
to achieve around about a one percent
saving on it I mean given the fuel
prices one percent is a lot of money and
every every cent counts as we say every
kilo account
while looking for savings safety remains
a priority
sahanger and Sydney were the enormous
A380 comes for Servicing thank you
so tall they had to raise the roof it's
so wide they had to widen the space
Jackie Scott has been a Qantas engineer
for 10 years safety before schedule
that's the Qantas motto well Airbus
actually dictates when most of our
components are changed so they may
decide that a particular Park needs
changing at 1 000 hours wanders will say
750 hours so we have a quarter of that
time
spare so if any unforeseen circumstances
we have a little bit extra time as well
as we just want to be as safe as
possible not leave things to the last
minute if choice is going to make his
Ultra long-haul program work he's going
to have to make sure his passengers want
to take the flights and one way to
entice them is the food this is our
little Test Kitchen right we do a few
events from here but mainly we do all
the testing for the menu
Qantas has got Top Chef Neil Perry
working with Scientists on menus to
enhance sleep and hydration for Ultra
long-haul flights here we have Danae who
looks after hello our cocktails which
have alcohol in them of course but also
our mocktails which is knocking out for
us now because the whole rehydration of
our passengers is a major Focus for us
especially on these Ultra long-haul
flights especially on the long-haul
flights
um thank you and you know it really is
all about
not tricking people but getting them to
drink as much delicious rehydration as
they can through we do a great infused
teas we do coconut water
[Music]
Harry and his chefs are constantly
working on creating food that is still
delicious at high altitudes we look at
that in relation to the Long Haul we try
to dial the spices and the chili down a
little bit stimulating spices are not
great when you're trying to relax the
whole idea is that we get proteins
starches beautiful leafy green
vegetables legumes those sorts of things
help really stimulate the sleep
just gears up toward beginning the
longest flights in its history Joyce
needs to remain Vigilant about the risks
that could once again buff at the
airline Qantas is not Invincible I think
what we saw in 2012 to 2014 really shows
that it was a near-death experience and
what Qantas faced at that point was a
war on two fronts it can lose money
internationally as long as it's making a
lot of money domestically but if both
divisions are facing pressure and losing
money then it's a really difficult
situation for Qantas and it can happen
again Joyce has pledged to stay on as
CEO until 2022 when the direct flights
to London and New York begin
the potential risks to the airline will
remain at the Forefront of his mind
we've been around for 99 years we're the
oldest continuous operating airline in
the world and we've always reinvented
ourselves at the disrupted ourselves
before somebody else's hands and I think
we're always on edge we're always
thinking where could the next disruption
come from what do we need need to do to
stay ahead of that game and we're very
much always concentrating on that
oh
[Music]
it's among the most profitable car
makers in the world yet in 2013 this
French car maker was facing bankruptcy
since then its new chief executive has
achieved a remarkable turnaround and
then done it again across the border in
Germany
I met the man who was one of Europe's
most influential car Executives at his
Paris headquarters five years ago you
were facing a near-death experience so
we need to keep on being agile we
understand how important it is to move
around the roadblocks and the more
chaotic the world around us is the more
agility is an asset for a company like
ours
[Music]
PSA owns the Brand's Peugeot Citroen DS
automobile Opel and voxel
2018 the combined group reported record
earnings and its Auto unit made a return
on sales of 7.6 rivaling its German
peers
profit was driven by sales of the
European car of the year the Peugeot
3008 SUV
the record result was also helped by
Opel Vauxhall which PSA bought from
General Motors in 2017 and turned around
after two decades of losses PSA was
really on its knees they lost 8 billion
dollars over two years most industry
observers had counted them out they were
too slow and then Carlos Taveras came in
and in the matter of a few years took
out a lot of cost improved efficiency
improved asset structure
tavares's turnaround formula was called
back in the race
cut the number of models in each brand
make more profit on each reduce the
numbers of platforms they're made on and
cut costs everywhere
he was capable to
convince other people that the number of
models they used to have in the group
was not fitting with the market
requirements and so reducing the the
manufacturing complexity was about to
revamp the product lineup and it was
very hard consistent to do that because
obviously it's affecting the the
organization around the plants and
obviously the reducing the cost was a
bit painful
[Music]
so it had been confusing customers DS on
top
Peugeot in the middle and Citroen the
value proposition
we want to focus the Creative Energy of
the company on a more limited number of
products completely aligned with the
expectations of the markets in which we
operate the transformation can be seen
in the share price reaching a low at the
end of 2012 at the depths of the crisis
since tavares's appointment was
announced at the end of 2013 the shares
have more than doubled
[Music]
sa has been transforming itself for
years I visited peugeot's birthplace at
Social in the Eastern France where the
vast plant is being modernized
the Peugeot Brothers started a rolling
steel mill in 1810 making saws coffee
pepper and salt grinders even cages for
crinoline dresses
so one of the things I branched out into
was to make penny farthing bicycles but
they were also making carriages and
carts that needed horses and then the
idea came up to the brothers Peugeot
what if we put an engine in front of our
carriage
[Music]
fast forward to the second half of the
20th century and Persia was one of the
most prestigious industrial jewels in a
resplendent France making cards for a
growing middle class
[Music]
in the 1970s it bought Citroen which was
struggling and PSA Peugeot Citroen was
born
but by the time the global financial
crisis hit in 2008 the company had
become unwieldy producing too many
models on too many platforms with brands
that confused consumers
between July 2007 and the end of 2008
the share price dropped more than 80
percent the company was burning through
billions
Peugeot needed outside help
by 2013 torque started for the French
State and China's dong Feng motor to buy
14 each
for the family to halve its Holdings and
Carlos Tavares was appointed
Tavares started his career in 1981 as a
test driver at Renault
by 2011 he was renault's Chief Operating
Officer second only to Carlos gone
then came the Bloomberg interview in
which Tavares laid out his personal
Ambitions it was really surprising
actually because here you have somebody
who is the right hand man for Renault
Nissan which was a very successful
company at the time didn't have any of
the problems that you see today
essentially saying I'd really like to
become a CEO and if I have to leave my
current company to do it I will
he didn't last much longer at Renault
after that no matter by the end of 2013
he was appointed to the top job at
Peugeot a month after assuming the CEO
position Tavares announced his
turnaround plan back in the race
he's a ruthless Cost Cutter and he's had
to be and that's why Peugeot has margins
at a similar level to the likes of BMW
over the past year although some of that
is to do with restruction charges and
just experience you know he's been in
the industry a long time
follow me
[Music]
he is at the helm Carlos Tavares has
managed to return not just Peugeot
Citroen to profitability but the German
car maker Opel as well
[Music]
the interesting thing is that we've got
French cars coming off the production
line and German cars coming off the same
production line the Peugeot 3008 and
opel's grandland X
two quite distinct cars when Tavares
first visited social his message was
clear
the first time that Mr Tavares came we
were in the body shop he sees the body
shop manager and he asks what is your
added value what is the return on
investments of this workshop and the
managers stood there completely
stupefied because that wasn't something
we were used to working with
today that has completely changed we
have changed the culture because
effectively today from the manager to
the operator we think about the cost
price we know that we have to be
competitive with countries where prices
are lower it was not very sophisticated
it was quite simplistic to a certain
extent you see people when I came to the
PSA group in December 2013 were working
like hell they were working 12 hours a
day eventually more and the more they
work
the more the results were read
so we started from a very simple
recognition which was that if we are in
trouble it's not because we're not
working enough
we are working like hell
one of the early challenges was to bring
France's unions into the fold it's very
difficult in Europe to take people out
of the workforce and you've got to
remember that Peugeot took quite a hefty
subsidy during the financial crisis to
save the company they had a three
billion rights issue as well but they
were very close to going bankrupt so I
think the unions accepted that they had
to cut costs and it's done been done
through natural attrition as well but
you know he's certainly taken people and
a lot of costs out the business
was capable to build up an aliens with
the POI from trade unions and just after
a couple of years it was it's crazy
because all the political driven trade
unions are reduced to silence because
for instance recently everyone was
granting a significant bonus in the firm
and so it's not possible for this trade
unions to uh to speak anymore but would
the unions become more difficult as PSA
group becomes more profitable with the
five unions I have in my company
representing 80 percent
of my people they have signed all the
Strategic plans all the performance
plans and they have been one of the big
supporters of this profitability
Improvement that we have delivered over
the five years I think they understand
that this is a this is a race you see uh
it is it is a competitive game that we
are facing every day I asked this
question to my unions um in December
2018 and I told them look guys we are we
are profitable our situation is very
good I can hear here or there some
tensions and some small issues I don't
want those issues to grow and I ask my
unions should I ease a little bit on the
accelerator pedal the back in the race
targets were met two years early
heralding the next stage of tavares's
plan back in the race and its
operational excellence outcome is the
foundation
on which we are going to put the
Strategic profitable growth plan that we
have called push to plus while back in
the race was about restructuring and
weeding out underperforming models
pushed to pass shifted the focus to
expansion as Tavares pushed to compete
with bigger rivals
thank you
PSA gets about 80 percent of its revenue
from the European market where
automakers face a consumer slowdown and
EU emissions regulations are
accelerating the adoption of electric
cars
sales in China are also a problem
Sinking by a third last year making the
car maker even more reliant on the
wobbly European market that explains its
goal to increase sales outside Europe by
50 percent by 2021. the first one will
bring the Peugeot brand to the US and a
Canadian Market second one will bring
Citron to the Indian market and third
one will bring the opal Bank to the
Russian Market those are the three big
announcements on which we are putting
our energy and our Focus to get there
Tavares expects his staff to go the
extra mile
this is this concept of the extra mile
that you talk about
where if one person fails because
everyone's doing the extra mile if you
manage the team only on the fact that we
cannot fail
and we have a very ambitious goal then
you are just adding tension stress in
the organization
and you are not giving anybody the
possibility to fail because if somebody
fails and the team loses as a result of
an individual failure then that that
person will be in trouble
which means that if you want to keep the
possibility for each of your team
members to fail
and at the same time
the team needs to win
means each team member needs to go one
extra mile beyond the is owned objective
to cover the risk that among one of
those team members there will be one
that can fail and that's very normal
because he's a human being you spoke to
Bloomberg in 2013 and you were talking
about how you would like you were at
Renault still okay and you were talking
about how you'd like to be the leader of
maybe Ford or General Motors so you've
been thinking about being material for a
chief executive for quite some time
where does your self-belief come from
possibly from the fact that since I was
a teenager I was immediately passionate
about cars and and then I became a
mechanical engineer start working for a
car maker at that point in time it was
renewed and went to Nissan overseas
Japan the United States and I I love
this industry it's such a highly
competitive industry because there are
many many contradictory things it's a
capital intensive uh profitability is
not very high the number one guy in the
industry is making 10 profitability
which is not such a big number now there
was an interview in uh lizek a French
newspaper and my office is abuzz with
one part of the interview the fact that
you're at home at seven o'clock every
night having dinner with your wife is
that true every every night when I'm
working here yes and that's the reason
why you have so much time pressure on
this interview all right because yes
because you've got to get home by seven
o'clock yeah are you trying to show a
new example for France
I'm trying to show you that we are here
to get results
not to make ours
and that's very very important you know
it happens to me
to tell some of my top executives
that they are working too much
it happened I said to one of them I say
hey I'm worried you seem tired you
travel too much and your working days
are too long and that's not good I want
you to keep some bandwidth where you can
step back the acquisition of Opel gave
PSA group a lot of heft when it comes to
scale
but is it enough to fund the autonomous
vehicle development as well as to
accelerate the switch to Electric by the
end of this year for example PSA has
pledged that each model developed by its
Brands will have an electric or hybrid
version you have to be very agile if not
even darwinyan which means if you don't
change you disappear
[Music]
apple is the latest automaker to benefit
from the Carlos Tavares turnaround touch
PSA bought the germany-based company
from General Motors alongside UK brand
Vauxhall in 2017.
his task now is to further integrate the
companies to save more money while
driving vital Investments for the future
you need scale there's huge Investments
that have been undertaken by the car
makers at the moment and one thing that
Persia didn't have before Opel was
significant scale so the addition of
Opel gives them Scout they're now at
close to 4 million units and that allows
these additional costs for new
technologies to be divided over a wider
product base
Opel lost nearly 20 billion dollars over
two decades
after a year of Tavares at the helm it
reported profit of nearly a billion
dollars in 2018. one horsepower and
basically the first car of open Tavares
tapped Michael Lo scheller Chief
Financial Officer at opal to head up the
division
Tavares he says change the way Opel
thought about making cars just as he'd
done it Peugeot Citroen the key point
from my perspective was a new mindset a
mindset really focused on performance
and implementing things
and then he also gave us a lot of
freedom for the important things of the
business in particular design and the
positioning of Our Brands Opel and voxel
[Music]
Oprah was how to make low margin cars in
a high-cost country profitably low
sheller got unions to agree to eliminate
nearly 4 000 jobs through buyouts
then there was a drive to reduce
manufacturing complexity one of our car
lines had 27 different steering wheels
but customers were not asking for 27
different steering wheels so we brought
this down to eight and that is one
tangible example and we have many many
more where actually we reduce complexity
without jeopardizing our customer offer
because obviously the customer is in the
focus of everything we do to get a
better idea of what a German car should
be I met with the design director who
showed me the Opel GTX experimental
concept car
[Music]
foreign
and German Precision is certainly
something which is ingrained in German
engineering and also in a certain kind
in German design and that also is
something which helps us to separate the
brands within the PSA group with the
three French ones and then the British
one and the German one into two
different directions which is great and
you can see it at the car I believe so
tell me what I should be looking at when
I'm looking at the the German Precision
over here well very clearly I think this
very proud this this bold face we call
it the visor which is encompassing all
the technical elements and actually what
we call it it's a techno Hub all the
high-tech elements like radar lidar all
these elements are kind of inside of the
visor and notice we don't have any door
handles since this is a show car a
concept car what we do is we open up the
whole site and we'll see it in a second
once we open it so the whole side of the
vehicle opens up
[Music]
despite initial success at Opel PSA
faces formidable headwinds
question is still about scale and how to
fund the huge Investments needed to
develop electric vehicles self-driving
cars and Mobility Services he's been
successful with his SUVs over the last
couple of years this is the fastest
growing segment going forward the
fastest growing segment will be electric
vehicles and because Tavares cut back
significantly on R D and capex over the
past four or five years which has
boosted his free cash flow will he have
the technical ability to compete with
its peers as opposed to just competing
on price because their cars aren't as
technically Advanced as as the likes of
the competition so once again when it
looks to coming to making deals and
alliances then for to virus that would
make sense if they went to someone who
already had some sort of pretty
significant Electric Car Technology
that's correct and if you look at the
German manufacturers since the financial
crisis they've made great success of
their sales in China the turnaround in
Europe as well and that's allow allowed
them to build their balance sheets and
they have very strong cash within their
balance sheets and that's allowed them
to invest heavily in electric vehicles
and autonomous vehicles over the past
two or three years that hasn't
necessarily been the case for Peugeot
because it's had to you know cut back in
these areas to bring its cash flow back
up to where we would expect for a
European car company Justice here PSA
has said to have been in talks with Fiat
Chrysler and jaguar Land Rover being
bigger may not help the maneuverability
of the company you have to be very agile
if not even darwinian which means if you
don't change you disappear so in that
direction you don't want to be bigger
you want to be very compact very agile
very darwinian on the other side if you
have a significant change in the
regulations that imposes on you very
significant Investments which are going
of course to be a burden for your for
your midterm plan and for your
profitability which is exactly what we
have here that may be one of the reasons
why you would like to share this burden
with other companies and have a volume
scale effect and sharing the burden of
those r d uh Investments that may be a
reason on the other side this is uh our
attitude we are as you mentioned we are
too small to have the Leisure of not
considering opportunities I think that
would be counterproductive so yes we are
open but we are not targeting any
specific company or entity just because
we have a strong balance sheet we are
highly profitable we have the technology
to face electrification we are
developing our autonomous technology so
why should we look for that as a simple
goal it is not a goal it is an
opportunity if it comes on the table
in the past five years Tavares with the
turnaround at Peugeot and opal has
resurrected two struggling car makers he
now finds himself at the center of a
rapidly changing Auto landscape as the
biggest players taught mergers and
alliances it's an arena he clearly
relishes and this is why I think the
pure we are living from now up to 2030
is going to be absolutely exciting and
despite the chaos I'm very very excited
I think this this pressure we have these
disruptions we have are going to create
breakdowns in the history industry and
that means that opportunities will be
will be there on the table
[Music]
astrazeneca's research facility in
Sweden
walls here are being torn down to
promote conversation between scientists
that could lead to Medical breakthroughs
it's also a message at the heart of a
stunning new headquarters taking shape
in Cambridge when AstraZeneca was
searching for a new chief executive in
2011 it was poised to lose 17 billion
dollars in sales due to expiring patents
Pascal sorio was appointed in 2012 his
task replenish the drugs pipeline since
his appointment the share price has
doubled the problem was that we had to
spend a lot of time doing rounds and
rounds of cost cutting
reorganization and doing Shelby bikes as
opposed to doing what what it was we
should be doing as an industry which was
really focusing on science and
developing medicines on day one sorio
suspended the BuyBacks sorio comes more
from an operational and r d background
and I think that the new people that
were put in charge were also the types
of people who were more focused on on
Innovation than than just sales and
driving so about the science absolutely
which is what pharmaceutical is about
sorio increased spending on research and
development
focused on cancer the fastest growing
space in Pharmaceuticals and emboldened
scientists to abandon unsuccessful
research you really have to make sure
you choose projects that will succeed
but it's almost as important to choose
the projects that you should not move
into phase three because if otherwise
you spend a lot of money going nowhere
estrogenica was in a situation where
they had been losing revenue for years
and years and really through a focus
back on science back on R D they were
able to launch a number of products and
the oncology business unit really
started growing and for the first time
in 2018 we saw AstraZeneca having the
energy having the spirit and showing the
growth numbers again and really
delivering on the r d pipeline if there
was a single thing sorio did to
demonstrate his tenure would be a new
dawn it was his championing of limpaza
an ovarian cancer treatment the previous
management had scrapped
it's now on its way to becoming a
blockbuster the moniker given to a
billion dollar seller
limpaza Sparks sorio's curiosity even
before he joined the company I talked to
key opinion leaders and I was really
intrigued because I saw this drug looks
interesting but they're not doing much
with it and in fact they have they had
announced a write-off they had decided
to stop the program and they had written
off the intangible the Goodwill that was
associated with this product project
and I still remember I went to an ex an
opinion leader an expert in the field
and I remember having this breakfast
meeting with him in the U.S and he
looked at me at some stage and he said
look what you're doing is almost
criminal because these drugs should
already be treating patients so I
arrived with a clear view that it was
one of the medicines I needed to look at
and in what what I found is a research
team that was really convinced this was
a great drug and had been trying to
convince the organization as old but had
not been successful
in 2017 U.S drug maker Merck agreed to
pay as much as 8.5 billion dollars to
share in the development of limpaza
which can also be used for pancreatic
and other cancers the drugs expected to
generate 2.5 billion dollars in Revenue
this year and next and along with other
key treatments like tigriso and infinzi
fuel the gains expected by analysts
through 2020. he has a nose for a drug
when we showed him the data for limpaza
when we returned the data photographso
he realized that these things could be
medicines and he helped us pull those
things through the pipeline into late
stage development and ultimately to
launch into patients that takes courage
but it also helps us accelerate and push
things faster that was tremendous you
know so things that were originally
blocked were now unblocked and were
moving really fast through the pipeline
[Music]
hello
AstraZeneca was formed in 1999 by the
merger of Sweden's Astra and xenica of
the UK it's based in the British
University Town of Cambridge where it's
surrounded by some of the most renowned
by a pharmaceutical researchers in the
world in our industry it's fundamental
there's nobody who wakes up one morning
saying okay I've got the solution to
develop discovering a new products the
work we do or requires people to work
together you need the scientists to
understand what the future profile is
going to look like what the potential
competitive angle is and what the
potential way of marketing it would be
and what the Physicians would say that's
a very long list of things to have to
deal with when you're dealing with a
program that needs to take 10 years to
come to Market having everyone together
and making sure that they're able to
talk to each other is a key driver many
pangolos showed me around the new campus
and explained how the building is all
about collaboration we're really placing
ourselves in the middle in the heart of
one of the best life sciences clusters
in the UK and actually probably in the
world the idea behind this building is
it's meant to be transparent porous
collaborative inviting to our partners
the people are interested in the science
that we're doing so that we really make
our science and our scientists
accessible and that's all part of our
cultural transformation inside this
construction there are these huge
Laboratories embedded into the building
there's going to be nine 19
000 square meters of them that's three
football pitchers all the way along here
there's going to be the deaths where the
scientists will write up their
experiment and then of course all the
support stuff I'm told they can't wait
to move in
but first fighting off Pfizer at the end
of the first day the bankers must have
felt a bit sorry for me they came and
they told me you know yeah we have to
tell you you have less than 10 chance of
remaining independent
[Music]
as a work on boosting astrazeneca's
drugs pipeline started to take off a
fresh threat appeared
fisa it would be one of the biggest
deals in all of Pharma history we know
that Pfizer had made an approach in
January you've got a keen buyer a very
keen buyer but perhaps not such a cane
seller in this trade in 2014 astra's U.S
rival made four attempts to buy it in
less than six months the final offer was
for 117 billion dollars it would have
been the biggest Pharmaceuticals
takeover ever it was really an
interesting day because I arrived in
London and opened my phone and my
daughter had sent me a message telling
me my mom my wife was at the hospital
with a pulmonary embolism so I called
her and she was fine but it was a bit of
a bit of a stressful day and then we
arrived at the office and we started
working the whole day with the lawyers
as you can imagine bankers lawyers and
our own people and at the end of the
first day the bankers must have felt a
bit sorry for me they came and they told
me you know yeah we have to tell you you
have less than 10 percent chance of
remaining independent
so that was at the end of that day I
thought wow that was that was an
interesting well you didn't believe them
clearly
actually sometimes you know when people
tell me a project has a low probability
of success and I believe in it I tell
them you know 20 is not bad actually
because I only had 10 percent of uh
chance of remaining independent as fisa
continued to chase to create the world's
largest drug maker by sales lawmakers in
Britain Sweden and the US grew
increasingly critical the most important
intervention we can make is to back
British jobs bring
[Music]
technology and that is why I asked the
cabinet secretary and my ministers to
engage with both companies right from
the start of this process
AstraZeneca rejected the deal
disappointing many investors this price
doesn't reflect the newest has any car
in the last 18 months we've made
enormous progress we're building our
Pipeline and we believe this pipeline is
going to deliver value
for patients of course but also for
shareholders you had the board on the
side but your investors many investors
say no it was the wrong thing to do
but I also understand that you managed
to use this situation as a way of
galvanizing the staff what happened
there yeah I think it uh it was of
course a stressful time for a stressful
time yes forever but in the company but
it was also a great time uh in
retrospect because it was a time when we
had this Burning platform of showing
that we could actually deliver value not
only to patients but also to our
shareholders we're just focusing on what
we were doing and it really galvanized
everybody to actually uh you know do
their best and that meant showcasing
that astrazeneca's future was bright
Soria projected a 75 increase in annual
revenue by 2023
and announced the company had 15 drugs
nearly ready to go almost double from
the year before he promised to investors
their shares would rise beyond the 55
pound offer price it took four years to
get there our job was to turn science
into medicine and ultimate get those
medicines to patients you looked at our
success rates from 2005 to 2010 our
success rate from drugs entering
clinical development first and human
experiments to launch were around four
percent today in the most recent
assessment we've done which was looking
at 2012 to 2016 our success rate has now
gone up to 20 percent we were very good
at focusing on large numbers of projects
but that actually had a relatively low
probability of being medicines today we
very much focus on the quality we
actually cut almost half of the projects
in the pipeline and even with that cut
we still improved our success rate
significantly so that was quality not
quantities hugely hugely important it's
important to remain Nimble and and fast
taste but in order to do that and make
decisions you yourself as a leader have
to have a fair quantity of self-belief
where does that come from
well it's actually a more than
self-benefits about belief in the people
you have around you believe in the
advice you get belief in in the culture
you've created and it's really about
digging in the data understanding what
Physicians think experts think and you
know aggregating all of this and
analyzing it and at the end of the day
it's about the belief of that you have
to take risks and then and then at some
point you have to accept you maybe if
you may fail what is it that you bring
to the organization that allows that
um that that communication to come out
and and for these drugs to be recognized
when it wasn't before one of the most
important time points is when you you
are in the phase one phase two and you
have to decide whether drugs should be
developed in phase three and here you
really have to look at it from all
angles and really understand where it
could help patients and how it could be
used in clinical practice and and the
way you do this is really by bringing
people together there and uh and and
really you know brainstorming and
debating And discussing the data and the
various opinions but also beyond that I
think you need to create the right kind
of culture one of the issues we had was
you know we had experience a few
setbacks in development we had three
products that failed in that stage
development in 2008 or something like
that and that happens all the companies
have experienced that but at the time
the management the company decided okay
well we're not going to fail again
and so you know when you tell people
we're not going to fail you never fail
in phase three because you never move
anything in first grade you've got to
really create an environment where
people feel comfortable taking some
educated risks
so it really is about
sharing knowledge sharing data debating
and being willing to take educated risks
we have entered into an agreement
of a global joint
interval and commercialization with
AstraZeneca sorio's most significant
educated risk so far was the 6.9 billion
dollar deal in March with Japan's
daiichi sankyo to develop a breast
cancer treatment that could even replace
chemotherapy potentially reshaping the
future of Cancer Care the potential is
very large
and we see it as a mega Blockbuster
AstraZeneca was obliged to partly fund
it with a 3.5 billion dollar share sale
highlighting the company's scarce cash
resources they needed to raise money
from the market and they raised a little
bit more because they have some debt
repayments coming up that I think
highlighted the cash flow needs of
course they could have gone and probably
given up some other rating and raised
debt again but that would have been
expensive people would say Equity is
expensive but at the end of the day this
was a much faster way of getting what
they needed and they did it but that's
if there's a focus on cash flow the diet
you deal why is that a key deal for
AstraZeneca I think people today don't
really understand fully the potential of
this medicine it can transform breast
cancer treatment and I personally
believe it can be a very big product and
I don't think people have totally
realized how big it can be
the emphasis on bringing people together
is a key plank of sorio's turnaround
the investment into buildings like this
in Cambridge
and these in Sweden is all about getting
people to come together and share ideas
company was operating in silos
and uh and actually not necessarily
believing in each other so you had a
commercial function and then you had a r
d function and and there was not a lot
of belief say in commercial that r d was
delivering and in r d we had also
fragmented teams we had the medimin team
we had you know very different many
different teams not working really
together
foreign
[Music]
site there is a huge model that shows
how existing and new buildings are going
to work together
most of the world's Brilliant Minds do
not work for Astra sanica we have 64 000
fantastic employees but most great ideas
are conceived somewhere else and if we
are going to take part of that we are
going to have to work completely
different with the external World jerkom
Raichel is one of those charged with
making the changes all right this is
clearly one of the modern new facilities
for research and development why does
this work more productively for
AstraZeneca as you can see it's a much
more open environment we have Torn Down
the Walls and we have scientists from
different disciplines working in this
environment which makes it easier for
collaboration why is it make it easier
are they working on the same disciplines
they're working on different diseases we
have scientists that they're researching
heart disease kidney disease and
respiratory disease and the interesting
thing is that those diseases have some
commonalities which now we can actually
understand better by having those
scientists working together at the same
space listen to before all of these
people would have been working
separately on their own disciplines they
would have been working in separate Labs
absolutely
another Innovation is the bioventure Hub
where companies are invited to establish
themselves inside the campus and given
the same access as the rest of the staff
what it means in practice as I said is
the talented people with new
technologies and new ideas will get
inside us a Seneca build their companies
build their develop their science and
they will do that together with a Seneca
formally informally this has a
completely different company so as an
example we today have our bioventure Hub
here at the company it's 34 external
companies same pass card as I have
access to our full site we share
knowledge
about 18 years ago when I joined
AstraZeneca we almost pulled down the
curtains before open a drawer that
that's a major major change that with
angered Katarina agu book the chief
executive of AstraZeneca Sweden says the
coffee Lab at the Gothenburg campus is
but one example of how the dynamic is
changing inside the company I think the
biggest thing is the cultural change in
how we operate in terms of opening up
working a lot more with the smaller
companies Academia and you know just
around the world collaborating more
externally not assuming we have the best
people every day inside but rather
opening up is one big thing
I also think actually the cultural thing
sometimes we forget that it's
he has been driving a very very values
driven way of working I think if you
walk around here or anywhere in
Australia everyone would know our five
values and it actually really means
something to people so you know we put
patients first we follow the science
we're entrepreneurial
we play to win and we do the right thing
sorio continues to make changes to gain
an edge in January he reorganized r d
into two divisions one to focus on
cancer the fastest growing and most
lucrative part of the industry and the
other to oversee the rest it wasn't
necessary because of the structure we
had in place served us very well for
about five years or so five years ago we
didn't have much in our pipeline we had
to create this uh early units that were
kind of a biotech unit coming up with
new products but as we were becoming
more successful with the full pipeline
the structure was playing against us a
little bit we were becoming a bit too
bureaucratic and too focused on
governance and our oncology pipeline in
particular has grown tremendously and
oncology is a little bit different from
the rest of pharmaceuticals so I decided
that the reorganization was necessary so
we could move very quickly from research
to early development to late development
in oncology bring people together from
research to development to commercial in
oncology but also in BIO Pharmaceuticals
and when it comes to building new
markets AstraZeneca like many is looking
to China and it's increasingly affluent
patients
when did you first begin to see China as
a key Market
uh almost immediately because you know
the as I started I really had to look
for
areas where we could grow you know I had
to look for the strengths of the company
and and number one where we could
rebuild the pipeline how we could re
build the power plant but also
looking at this massive Planet expiry
that we were facing where could I find
growth and China was one of those and in
fact the pipeline of the portfolio of
products we had and still have really
addresses the needs of patients in China
so immediately I thought you know we
have to invest in China and keep going
since becoming astrazeneca's CEO sarrio
has refocused the company on science
he's reconfigured buildings to open them
to outside minds and ideas and he's
replenished the company's pipeline 2012
Astra Seneca was a completely different
company we had
great sales great profit and virtually
no pipeline whatsoever this is the time
that Pascal sorio came into the company
and that the company changed leadership
so if we fast forward from that time
about five or six years
from
almost no pipeline whatsoever
some analysts claimed that we had the
best pipeline in the industry
questions remain about the dearth of
cash flow highlighted by the daiichi
deal the issue for Astra is that there's
only so much cash and as we know that is
one of the key questions around the
company let's go more into that though
so why is that a question well
pharmaceutical companies are
historically great cash generators
there's two reasons people have
historically invested in pharmaceutical
companies one is the the fact that
they're driven by demographics and they
are a defensive sector normally and the
other one is that they throw off tons of
cash so where the cash flow becomes a
bit thinner that becomes a question and
of course there's not much you can do in
three say roughly five billion dollar
products at the same time are going off
patent and products at the end of their
lives are very profitable because they
don't need much detailing how do you you
know how do you replace that that's
that's a pretty difficult thing to do
that said fazelli says astrazeneca's
latest results did indicate that cash
flow is going to improve on the back of
growth and high margin products
as far as sorio is concerned it's not
his biggest worry
witness a decision announced in June to
invest 630 million dollars over the next
five years in the South Korean Health
Care sector or a 220 million dollar
commitment to Vietnam's Health sector
unveiled in May the bigger risk for us
is to become complacent actually you
know it's interesting we didn't have
anything
we then wear a potentially Acquired and
there was an enormous burning platform
for all of us to do our best and work
hard and move fast and as you become
successful you can become slower and
more complacent so that's the one thing
really we I don't want to see happen
[Music]
it was a Triumph of social media
marketing
feel good exuberance mob in New York's
iconic Grand Central Station
at the dawn of the Instagram age
[Music]
today is a media in general it's not
anymore newspaper Magazine TV radio
today's media means you have to attract
the track
a community you have you really have you
have to talk with them every day
[Music]
when montclair's chief executive Raymond
ruffini staged his New York spectacular
sent cyclists into Milan's velodrome or
took over the Lincoln Center
he'd already stepped outside the
traditional boundaries of the catwalk
into the realm of the theater Welcome to
The Winter Palace tapping into the
social media Zeitgeist that had helped
Propel an almost bankrupt French ski
wear company into the upper echelons of
global fashion
[Music]
now he's taking a new risk
in 2018 rafini announced he was going to
ditch the business model that had
supported the turnaround of the failing
company he'd bought in 2003 when he
propelled it from a mid-ranking ski gear
maker to a business among the most
profitable listed luxury companies in
the world
but ruffini has refused to rest on his
laurels in an effort to prepare the
company for the next stage of expansion
and turbocharged sales he announced a
new way of doing business
instead of spring summer winter fall
men's and women's he now has a
collection every month with eight
different designers he dubbed it genius
for me it's an incredible instrument of
communication because he could have
something to talk about to the market
every month
with the famous designers nice images of
products very Innovative products
strange products so it's incredible
reach of content this approach this
collection allows them to with great
frequency
be sharing something new be bringing
different influencers targeting
different sub segments of their of their
consumer base and they give them a lot
to talk about on social media it's
probably the most valuable asset that
they have on social media today they
really are working on what Montclair
will be in five years time
so I think that this approach long-term
approach
could be a guarantee that they could
still have room to to grow David Tweed
what I wanted to ask first is what is
the essence of Genius
so you're really content content on
content the people they need content
they need the people need ideas then at
the end of the day they need also
product to go into the stores but you
know our strategy is based to attract
people every month in the stores but not
only to sell a jacket but it's you know
also to participate to our to our let's
call Festival you know and again our our
strategy is based on all generation
means every month we we like we want to
talk with different Generations
[Music]
work the year of the launch sales Rose
by a fifth the fastest Pace in three
years and the share price has staged a
recovery after its steady Ascent stalled
briefly at the end of last year the way
that it works is that they're using the
base of their history but allowing
creativity individual to individually to
those collaborators that reaches a much
younger audience speed of audience is
very much a cachet on digital and
e-commerce and creates a buzz around
other products that are available under
the Montclair brand like this puffered
jacket for dogs a snip at 425 dollars
in the fourth quarter of 2018 Montclair
was the biggest gainer in ranking of
luxury searches compiled by list a
global fashion search platform
genius diffusion lines drop monthly and
were responsible for the Brand's biggest
spikes in both social engagement and
search volume genius is about how do I
give something for my consumers to talk
about on a regular basis right one of
the challenges of traditional luxury is
there is an inherent conservatism in
some ways right I need to stand for
something consistent I can't be
refreshing all the time yet that makes
it difficult in a social media world
what do I talk about every week and if
I'm not talking to my consumers every
week they're not listening so this these
collaborations the the frequent launches
allow them to have something to talk
about you know represent less than 10 of
their sales a day but I would expect
half of what's discussed on social media
if you can measure it another crucial
thing in the fashion industry today is
that you have something that is limited
today everybody wants in the market
something that is limited you know you
collect watches you collect shoes you
collect whatever so it's a trend for me
it's very important for the genius also
that the fact that every month you have
a collection you have a designer and
that's it then you cannot buy anymore
in 2003 ruffini bought Montclair a 50
year old French sportswear company on
the brink of insolvency montclair's
sales were less than 50 million euros at
the time last year turnover was 1.4
billion I was very familiar with the
brand because in Italy in the 70s was
very very popular
and I bought my first monthly was like
14 15 years old I was living out of my
own town is Como my house was a little
bit out of Como like six seven
kilometers and every morning I use my
motorcycle to go to the school when I
was 14 15 at that time was much more
cold than today
and I always use this jacket very bright
very shiny
Montclair is named after monastia de
Clermont an Alpine town in France
founded in 1952 it made tencent quilted
sleeping bags and its workers wore
quilted coats to keep warm
Mountaineer Lionel Terry saw them and
suggested Montclair outfit his 1954
expedition to K2 considered the world's
most dangerous mountain to climb Akili
company and Lino Laci Valley were the
first to successfully reach its Summit
in 1954. kitted out in Montclair
the brand became a favorite among the
Jet Set Bridget Bardot
Jackie Kennedy
the Empress of Iran
but when rafini bought it the company
was on the skids buffeted from
competition from the likes of Prada and
the North Face that time was a trendy
brand but it was mainly a skewer brand
so you had basic colors I remember you
had the yellow red blue but nothing to
compare with today of course yes after a
while I think in the the end of the 80s
beginning in 90s they lost their way it
was still I think a French brand at that
time and then Mr rufini came over the
brand and decided to to buy it try
looking for something real with the
strong roots and after six seven months
looking for the market I realized
Montclair was
could possible available and after one
year talking I bought the brand and this
was a fantastic fantastic example to
redesign the company we keep to keep the
roots as as close as you can I think you
talk about the DNA a lot right yeah a
lot because I think you have to respect
especially when you have a brand they
have a very strong DNA wired through
this on the garbage or whatever I think
is very important to keep the DNA to try
to be modern to be try to improve
everything but the DNA is very very
important
[Music]
ruffini decided to move the company here
to Milan Italy's fashion Capital people
tell me though that that you are
considered to be a master in brand
Rejuvenation okay so what did you do
when you first went into Montclair in
2003 and you looked at the range and
thought okay this is how we're going to
take this brand forward how did you do
it what were the the nuts and bolts of
that
honestly nothing's special come on
honestly I went there I started working
really on the small things you know I
started working on first in the product
in the quality to redesign the ideas
because at the end of the day you you
need you need a big brand but you need
also a contemporary product
[Applause]
this is the global puffer jacket this
was Rhema ruffini's big idea to take a
piece of outerwear that was normally
only used on the slopes when you're
skiing or in Alpine Expeditions and turn
it into a luxury item that people would
like to wear in town
you developed this idea of the global
down jacket yes because for me it was
important not only to remain on this
kind of stores not only used for hiking
or climbing also I think it was a big
potential to use this product also
walking to the street you know that's
why I start working on quality and
weight on performance on all these kind
of things I read one you were looking at
people in an air in an airline or in in
an airplane they just arrived from New
York
yes because uh since when I bought the
company I bought one jacket I use as
soon I realized it was impossible to use
because one day you go New York is cold
maybe it's okay with your jacket but
then you fly you fly to Tokyo is 22
degrees you don't know where you put the
jack is huge right you don't have enough
space on the bag to put the jacket and I
say lightness is very important you know
softness and everything on that I really
work on technology I really work on
weight I really work on this kind of
thing and then as I started walking
around the water to understand what is
the potential of this brand and
understand which kind of kind of people
they can use they can use in the city or
not only in the mountain and then
after one year I really try to move the
brand from the as I say Sport Goods
stores into more luxury environment
once he got the product right ruffini
executed the next part of his plan the
gam Rouge line for women the first time
skiwa had been presented as fashion
followed by Gambler for men
[Music]
with each show becoming more of an event
an Autumn forest for the girls
strobing striptease for the boys
to say nothing of the 2009 Grand Central
Station flash mob an event almost
perfectly timed with Instagram becoming
a thing then came the stores
this is the Via Monte napoleoni it is
without doubt the most prestigious
luxury fashion Street in all of Italy
Prada Ferragamo Armani so it makes
absolute sense that when Montclair
decides to expand and open a flagship
store in Milan
it shoots as this location yes after two
three years you know late 2008 they said
to open my first store I said where I
opened the stores you know it could be
you know champions
We decided to go straight to to the most
Luxury Street in Europe basically one of
the most relaxed Street in Europe we
opened in small stores in in
honestly we feel
since when we opened the doors that the
brand was a good good receipts from this
kind of customer you know we have line
outside every day basically and managing
your own distribution though that's
something that's also key isn't it
I think in the beginning this was
another turning point I decided to
basically cancel all distribution agent
license really I think my dream was
really to control 100 my since the day
one my everything and we can sell all
the partner because you know it's quite
conflict of interest I want to build up
a brand that they won't sell sell and
sell
and I start my retail business my alone
I open my store directly my not only in
Paris all around the world from China
Japan United States I mean it was much
more difficult but I the good thing I
control the process I think control
everything have this fast feedback from
the market understand what's going on
especially at the beginning when we have
like three four five stores I call them
every night you know to understand
what's going on
now is little bit more difficult but
with data you can have the same feedback
there is a real concerted effort to open
up retail you also saw a move away from
wholesale right so into that retail
transition so this was the period I
would say of real expansion becoming a
global brand right and and really
putting down starting to put down a lot
of flags here in Asia
you can see the importance of the retail
strategy here retail sales the pale
orange bars easily outpace wholesale the
bright orange bars still ahead how Rima
rafini developed his China strategy this
is montclair's Hong Kong flagship store
it's one of about half a dozen outlets
in the city and it is vast we're looking
at 500 square meters of retail space it
was the biggest Outlet in all of Asia
until the beginning of the year when a
bigger store opened in Singapore ruffini
thinks that China is where the growth
and luxury is going to be Montclair is
just getting started
[Music]
nearly a decade after buying the company
ruffini decided it was time to take
Montclair public
second attempt after the first was
foiled by the market upheaval
surrounding the Greek crisis
it was a way for rafini to arrange an
exit for his private Equity investor
without having to turn to new private
Equity funding since the beginning of
private equity in my company they helped
me to buy the company at the beginning
was meeting then catalyzed that is an
American priority he came to the to the
company and after that as you know they
need an exit basically in Carolina late
2009 2010 to me we need to exit at least
a part
I don't want to start again to make you
know raising the or another private
ticket say okay let's try to go public
in the end Carlisle sold its 45 stake to
French private Equity company or azeo in
the winter of 2013 Montclair has its
initial public offering it turns out to
be the most successful in Europe that
year the shares rise 41 on the first day
of trading valuing the company at 3.6
billion Euro about 5 billion US Dollars
Raymer rafini becomes one billion
dollars richer
you're a Zeo hung onto it stake for
eight years selling the last five
percent in March
over the years its investment generated
a return of 1.4 billion euros and an
internal rate of return of 43 percent
[Music]
the IPO funds helped back the expansion
into China that started in 2011. a
market that partly inspired rafini to
launch genius
[Music]
ruffini says the key is first of all to
establish the brand
and the stores will follow I think the
future of luxury is for sure China I
think we are still very small in China
three four years ago I decided that in
China it was better to sell brand brand
perception than sell jacket we're not
open to many stores I think we have a
huge possibility to increase our size of
the store increased number of doors at
the moment we got less than I think 30
stores so right now for you China is
about selling brand perception it's like
you're preparing the market I think it's
very important because unfortunately
10-year channel will be the biggest
Market I don't know if in 10 years I
will be there you know it means the most
important things to remain strong in
China is to build up a very strong brand
for sure the Mac will be the biggest
[Music]
it's a prediction shared by others in
the industry I think it's important to
recognize the secular trend of the
growing affluent in China so there is a
lot of news and volatility that we read
about the trade War right we if we were
sitting here in 2013 we would have been
talking about anti-corruption which
actually took a big gifting portion of
the luxury goods Market away right and
then all of a sudden there was a lot of
naysayers on the China luxury Market but
actually what was still happening is
still happening today is a very
consistent growth of the Chinese
affluent and that's why we predict
there'll be up to 40 percent of the
global luxury Market by 2023 because
it's a secular growth of the segment so
there'll be some ups and downs but the
the overall trend is still there 40 from
what uh it's about 32 today
[Music]
the Chinese market is vast but not
necessarily easy like when Dolce and
Gabbana released a marketing video
depicting a Chinese Beauty trying to eat
pizza with chopsticks it didn't help the
Brand's reputation when one of the
founders let fly with an attack on
China's netizens
the boycott ensued
that's an issue when Chinese Shoppers
are estimated to account for at least a
third of luxury sales and two-thirds of
the industry's growth how do you go
about avoiding making cultural errors in
a market which is let's face it it's a
foreign market
I think in the city before since the
first day we decided to go directly in
every Market a team is very important
team you build there is very important
because I always stay I always say to to
the guys who have to be domestic because
this is very important because the
culture the language everything is
totally different I cannot talk the same
language in Japanese or in Beijing even
if it is one hour flight the country is
so different that you need something
local to help you but at the same time
you have to be domestic my for sure you
need a global vision because otherwise
you become a domestic company being
means is the mix you know and the team
you have in the region is very very
important it's a fine line to balance
you know I think if you've seen recent
scandals Dolce Gabbana it's important to
have a sensitivity to understand who
your consumers are have it in in place
some of the governance and guard rails
to help contain the conversation to be
appropriate and inspiring for for who
those consumers but if you do make a
mistake then how do you react to it I'm
sorry right and sometimes I mean I think
there's you know there are probably many
approaches to this being upfront and and
straightforward and not letting you know
the the thing fester for a long time it
was probably one of the better ways to
execute right in the face of a of a
significant error or mistake
[Music]
Montclair success questions do remain
about whether it's a risk to base an
entire business on one product a puffer
jacket we see huge growth potential in
the puffer Jack of its Heritage its
history its base its foundation
there isn't a huge amount of competition
out there so we would say that there's
definitely longevity there and even
around the new
design implementations and one of
collaborations that they have going on
the puffer jacket provides the base so
the answer would be no we see long-term
growth Prospect for the puffer jacket
genius was as much a device to create a
conversation with customers as it was to
shake up his own company after 10 years
in my feeling was everybody sleep a
little bit in the company
and I think we have to we say we have to
change something we have to attract
different customers we have to we
thought everyone was a bit asleep in the
company yes because after 10 years also
myself yeah also myself because the
business was always the same you have
two fashion show here you know spring
summer we have done winter and then the
upper spring summer autumn winter spring
summer to win I think this this war they
need much more energy
and that's why we decide to move our
ideas from seasonal business into
monthly business
for rafini the biggest risk facing his
business isn't an over-reliance on a
single product or the vagaries of a far
away Market
it's at home
the bigger risk I think is us the team I
think as I said before the world change
very fast
if you if you if we not follow the word
we're gonna lose
[Music]
foreign
in April this year the Danish beer maker
Carlsberg put its reputation on the line
when it launched an advertising campaign
that admitted its beer in Britain wasn't
what it was supposed to be
it was an admission that could only come
as a result of a profound change in the
culture of the company brought about by
this man case to Heart a Dutchman with a
reputation for forging Unity from
division
well when I came in this business I
started to talk with many people I think
I had 200 interviews and everybody more
or less had the same this is a siled
company when kesterhard arrived at
Carlsberg in 2015 he found a company
demoralized by a badly timed investment
in the Russian Market that had forced it
to stand on the sidelines of a wave of
Brewing industry consolidation what is
special about the Carlsberg turnaround
is really how case the heart has
triggered the turnaround by returning
the company to its original purpose that
the founder set out and really engaging
the workforce when I think back to 2015
I suppose what for me was very different
about Carlsberg versus today was I don't
think we had any real Clarity on the way
forward we looked at our competitors we
looked at the industry consolidation
that was happening and was happening
pretty fast at that time and there was a
lot of concern about the future now what
is the Carlsberg 1883 when I met close
to heart I wanted to ask how do you deal
with all these issues at once we put it
together in a strategy which is called
cell 22. so we have the a seven year
program if you like the start of a
journey
on the other hand we realized ourselves
together with our top people that we
didn't have the money to do the journey
so we said okay let's do two things we
create the future for ourselves and
that's then called cell 32 but we front
our own Journey
reluctant to our shareholders for funds
to hard adopted to cut costs and invest
the Savings in premium brand strategy
the plan addressed the concerns that had
prompted the Carlsberg Foundation which
has controlled the Brewer since 1876 to
seek out a new chief executive in the
first place the Brewers debt had been
mounting turnover and profit was down
stemming from the decision in 2008 to
take full control of baltica Russia's
leading beer brand a move that turned
spectacularly sour because after that
deal Russia accounted for a third of
carlsberg's revenues just as a
Countrywide alcoholism epidemic prompted
the government to crack down on sales
and increase taxes on beer by 200
percent
[Music]
2014 another blow International
sanctions after Russia's incursion into
Ukraine undermined its economy
carlsberg's Eastern European sales
slumped it meant that as the margins
declined and as the overall
profitability declined they were
unable to react in that market and then
it removed any Firepower for them to
participate in significant M A in other
markets or even to support other markets
with with the kind of marketing spend
that would be required versus very
strong and very deep pocketed
competitors
that wave of mergers and Acquisitions
had led to the creation of companies
like
anheuser-buschinbev or ABI a brewing
Behemoth nine times carlsberg's size
[Music]
think of the turnaround it's called
funding the journey the idea was to cut
costs to free up cash to invest in the
growth leg of the turnaround dubsale 22.
breweries were closed in Russia and
China to get rid of excess capacity
Supply chains revamp to strip out costs
the results can be seen in a net debt to
earnings chart it peaks in 2008 the
purchase of the Russian Brewery it drops
onto Hearts 2015 appointment as his cost
savings are used to pay off debt and his
investments in Brands improve earnings
so although basically taking the cost
out of the business so that you could
then release cash to invest in the core
business in the core Brands uh also
reduce your debt from it was around
about three times that that when you
came in so that you could reduce that
debt and actually release cash to doing
m a
the funding the journey program it's not
something that was finite Carlsberg is
continually striving to cut costs and
improve efficiencies which is why this
machine here has just had its head
redesigned so it can pick up not just
one but two of carlsberg's newest
products the draft master
and this is a draft Master it's a new
type of lightweight kig
but it's still pretty heavy what's
really interesting is that all of the
production of this type of keg is done
in this plant instead of all around
Europe they bring the beer in it turns
out it's much cheaper and it's still
part of funding the journey
second leg of the turnaround sale 22 is
a Five-Year Plan designed to generate
sales growth through investment in
premium Brands as well as specialty and
no alcohol beers
the impact can be seen here last year
the value of sales increased 6.5 percent
while beer volumes climbed just under
five percent Carlsberg is selling more
expensive beer
this strategy can be seen directly in
the real and projected gains in earnings
per share and a share price near record
levels Carlsberg has taken out a lot of
cost through the funding the journey
program and then they've used that money
to invest into growth into really moving
the company up up Market again and
really get back to a winning streak
[Music]
cognizant that Carlsberg needed to
invest and loathe to ask shareholders to
forego dividends case to Heart came up
with a two-pronged turnaround strategy
but he had to get Senior Management on
board he bought and built Clarity around
the strategy around how he saw us
growing and how he saw us funding that
growth in a way that was stretching but
everyone felt was realistic I think the
other part of that was the way that he
did that and basically we said look we
have an issue here
we have this satisfies shareholders we
look at our feedback of our people they
are not satisfied our supervisory board
is not certified our customers have the
feel that we don't come with the right
rules and Innovation and so on sort so
really we have an issue
um and um I'm not going to solve that
issue for you we are going to solve the
tissue and that means that we're going
to co-create the Future that's been
pretty shocking pretty shocking for a
lot of those people in the room how many
of those top 60 then in 2015 are still
in the top 60. yeah I raise that
question uh of course I knew who were
new but um we were in December 2018 in
Belgium in greenberger where one of our
Visa is coming from and
um there were 22
hands up at the moment that I asked who
was with us at the other third about a
third so that's a pretty telling
statistic you've had a pretty big
turnover at the top in the management
now they haven't necessarily left
Carlsberg but uh I think most of them
did right we started really from the top
so we really started with the executive
committee and at the moment you start to
bring in new people in your executive
committee they start as well to work
with people they really feel can do the
work for the future and and change
people
[Music]
foreign
I want to show you this Carlsberg
building because it's very special it's
built around an old Silo in the middle
part there are no windows so that
becomes a sort of void but it's more
than a symbolic void it's a physical
void case to heart's office when he
became CEOs on the top floor and he used
to say to his staff I could die up here
and no one would find me for three days
because no one's walking past so what
he's done is he's moved his office from
the top floor down to the second floor
that means he's in the thick of it he's
collaborating he's communicating to
heart is taking his move from the top
floor to the second floor one big step
further a completely new headquarters it
will be over there in the q1 2020 but
then we will be in a totally new office
where
everybody has open Office there's only
four floors in total and the consequence
of that is that we will all mingle
together and by that I think there will
be much more energy in the business or
even more energy in the business people
come in and see that it's a contemporary
business that's not what the kind of
field you have at the moment you step in
now
one of the other concerns at the
Carlsberg Foundation was that the
company had veered from the vision laid
out by the founder J.C Jacobson in the
19th century that profits of the company
would be channeled to support art
science and culture
[Music]
The Little Mermaid is the number one
tourist attraction in Copenhagen
commissioned by Carlsberg Carl Jacobson
the son of the founder fell in love with
the story by Hans Christian Anderson
about a mermaid who gave up everything
in order to be able to swim to the
surface and be with her beloved but then
she died but the link with Carlsberg
goes on because Carlsberg Foundation is
still funding the Arts here in Denmark
Carl Jacobson founded the glypto ticket
a museum devoted to sculpture in
downtown Copenhagen that was packed the
day I visited
and it was this contribution to society
the foundation's purpose that Fleming
besenbacker wanted to nurture when he
was looking for a new chief executive
what was it about cage the heart that
made you think that he was going to be a
fit for Carlsberg and also the
objectives of the foundation why did I
take him well I think first of all in
case I've done a fantastic turnaround in
the first time computer and I could see
a turnaround voice also needed in
Carlsberg between 2009 and 2015 tahada
presided over the successful integration
of two Dutch Dairy cooperatives which
before the merger had considered
themselves to be virtual enemies but
also from talking to him he specifically
said to me if I take this job I do not
take it only if this was an ordinary job
just to create value for shareholders
I've been used to work for farmers in
the Netherlands
if I take this job I would like to work
for Sciences in Denmark and with the
foundation and so forth here also was
willing to focus on the purpose also
willing to focus on sustainability one
of the things about Carlsberg that I've
been hearing a lot about is
purpose-driven leadership now can you
explain what is that about what is it
well basically it comes back to why why
would you come to the office uh what is
basically you think that you and your
colleagues can contribute not only to
the business but maybe a broader
perspective as well so it comes and
that's where we started what is the the
what the how and the why and many
companies start with the Y but we were
finding that a bit difficult to find the
the why at the beginning had it been
lost the why at Carlsberg we think so
and it took me personally almost nine
months to 12 months to really find the
the why what about your own journey in
leadership
well I think the biggest decision in my
life was to move out of HR the point
that really made me think was having an
uh an exit talk with a person that
needed to be fired and was as old as my
father
and the decision was not taken by myself
so I I was a if you like literally
almost executor and I thought this is
not how I would like to to spend my life
to execute things that other people have
have decided
and then I started to feel like how will
I come to well maybe not CEO of a
company but in leadership roles in the
universe that was very much uh via
marketing so I moved from HR to
marketing and then moved the letter to
General management one of the things
I've heard you describing your
management team is is like a football
yeah team uh and not everyone's a
striker it is head office against the
countries it's marketing against sale
it's Finance again the rest of the the
rest of the world so it felt a bit like
this is a company let's say that we have
30 countries that we are playing or 30
different soccer fields and one of the
first pictures I showed to people so
well we are now all playing in different
teams on different soccer fields we are
now in in the future one team and that
means that we have the guys in the in
the countries they are the strikers they
need to score the goal so it means as
well that they need to know everything
about the consumer and the customer in
their country then we have a few
midfielders supply chain group
commercial these are the people that
need to make the plans passing the ball
if you like or the plans at the right
moment with the right specs and so once
forward but they are not scoring the
goals I never see people in the defense
like HR and finance and legal and they
need to make sure that we don't make big
mistakes or develop our people and so
forth
coming up more from case to heart and
the UK advertising campaign and what it
tells you about the new Carlsberg so why
don't we have a beer
let's do that
[Music]
when Keystone heart joins Carlsberg he
launched a dual recovery plan savings
and growth
there was also cultural change and
that's where carlsberg's purpose
statement comes in I started to talk
about uh that we Brew for better today
and basically we talked about the the
quality and the Brews and basically that
we needed to perform better but as well
about the future we we set a certain
moment we Brew for better today and
tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
showed he was prepared to walk the walk
in one of carlsberg's key 18 Western
European markets
in Britain Carlsberg was traditionally
made with a 3.8 alcohol content lower
than elsewhere where the taste was
richer and as more craft beers came into
the UK Market tastes evolved leaving
carlsberg's Brew behind you name a
Goldman worked on the strategy for
carlsberg's advertising agency in London
we realized that
the market was starting to shift and
people's
tastes and priorities and palettes were
changing people were demanding better
quality beer so it wasn't as much about
consuming loads and loads of it it was
about consuming beer that you thought
was of good quality and we realized that
Carlsberg had started to suffer from a
perception issue first and foremost
it's like drinking the bath water your
nandied in
Carlsberg announced it had changed its
beer and introduced new Carlsberg in the
British Market it was a brave campaign
because you have to admit your mistakes
and in the UK Market anyway the the
Carlsberg brand was probably thought of
as a mainstream brand rather than
premium and it's premium everywhere else
in Europe and that is the way they want
to take the beer and the beer suffered
Danish Superstar mads Mickelson told the
UK audience that we dance don't cry in
for our beer
we focus on brewing a better one brewing
for a better today that means that we're
never satisfied with what we have and
that's I think what we recognized in the
UK maybe the consumers earlier than we
did because we saw our market share
declining and that means that the
customer and the consumers don't like
your brand anymore so we digged into it
to that and we looked at the the Brews
and we we improved if you look at the
recent advert in the UK where they they
said Carlsberg you know probably not the
best the best beer almost
um being self-deprecating regarding what
had been a platform of their their
advertising for for years then that that
really indicates a flexible mindset
towards towards Brands and a recognition
that you need portfolios that satisfy
the needs of local consumers in in
individual markets
[Music]
to heart's efforts to return to the
scientific underpinnings of the founder
of felt here in the Carlsberg research
laboratory
which over the years has delivered
breakthroughs such as the first
cultivation of pure yeast and the
invention of the pH scale
and so these are all the Brews well this
I actually do when people have been
employed with Carlsberg or here in the
Carlsberg laboratory for more than 25
years then you get your own bottle of
beer and look here's mine oh it's a big
one looks like shampoo yeah it does and
there was a beautiful you know wheat
passion fruit lager oh very nice tell me
more about what's happened since uh
since we've seen case to Heart come to
uh to Carlsberg because I believe
there's there's been more integration I
think there has been a lot of
integration and there has been a lot
more of agility but also I would say
that you know hear from a research point
of view we have been very much
integrated now into the whole business
and especially into all the Strategic
priorities for sale 22 really how so
well I think you know we have a lot of
focus now on really supporting the
Strategic areas like Core Beer making a
difference in that craft and Specialty
non-alcoholic beer and here at the
research laboratory can really support a
lot with completely new types of yeast
strains producing normal alcohol and
there are also other types of yeast
strain that can give a consumer benefit
better taste experience Aromas and so on
and that plays into sales 22 because
it's got the focus on Corby but also new
products yes it does very much so again
I would say we are today very very much
on the agenda in you know the whole
commercial agenda and we are today very
much in front also you know when we have
commercial meetings and when we have
visitors and so on so again I think
that's also the history of the
laboratory Carlsberg has quite a unique
history when it comes to research and
Science and it's basically also having
the more fundamental science which was
founded here in the laboratory
one of carlsberg's key areas for growth
is Asia the driver of its most recent
Revenue gains particularly where we see
a lot of growth coming from is in
premiumization so driving into more
premium categories more premium Brands
and that's really been a fantastic
driver for us in China for instance
where we have a good Geographic
footprint and some very strong positions
in some specific markets but we're
really looking to expand Beyond those
and to launch into new cities and to
particularly launch with the more
premium brands in the portfolio
since 2014 carlsberg's increased its
share of the premium Market in China to
14 from 9 percent
while Abi's share has dropped to 43
percent
[Music]
trying to help drive a 9.5 increase in
carlsberg's 2019 first quarter beverage
sales in Asia which now accounts for a
third of carlsberg's Total Beverage
sales still ABI represents a threat
alongside Heineken which last year
struck a partnership deal with China's
biggest Brewer
you know China as I say Carlsberg have
done a very good job there but you would
imagine that in the areas of and
channels in China where Carlsberg have
been doing well there will be
competitive pressures coming in
Carlsberg is well aware of the
competitive challenges it faces but even
so to hear it from the people I talked
to at Carlsberg during my visit there
case to Heart seems to have succeeded in
injecting a new sense of yes I'll use
his word purpose into the company the
question is how to keep the momentum
going by renewing ourselves if you like
setting the sales tweaking it making
sure that we keep our speed having three
times a year the top 60 being
self-critical or are we really
delivering maybe sometimes being a bit
paranoid as well about whether the wind
is coming from Another Side than we
expected whether the waves are a bit
higher than the the forecasted these
kind of things and the top team is
really very good at it what advice would
you give to another chief executive who
was looking at a company that also needs
to be turned around
uh plan for the worst and don't have a
promise
[Music]
foreign